In April 2003, the Human Genome
Project was declared completed,
putting an end to the 13-year long
scientific endeavor. What is the
human genome project? What is inside the human
genome? And, how to sequence the human genome?
These are some of the questions that
we will try to address in this lecture.
The Human Genome Project is an international
research effort to sequence and map all of the
genes of Homo sapiens. The project began in
1990 initially headed by James Watson at the
U.S. National Institutes of Health. Largely due to
his disagreement with his boss, Bernadine Healy,
over the issue of patenting genes,
he was forced to resign in 1992.
He was replaced by Francis Collins in April
1993, and the name of the Center was changed to
the National Human Genome Research Institute
in 1997. A working draft of the genome was
released in 2000 and a complete one in 2003,
with further analysis still being published.
In May 2006, another milestone was passed
on the way to completion of the project,
when the sequence of the last chromosome
was published in the journal Nature.
Completed in April 2003, the Human Genome Project
gave us a complete representative sequence of the
human genome. The representative sequence is
a composite from several people who donated
blood samples. Originally, close to 100 people
volunteered to give a sample of their blood. Each
person provided their informed consent, affirming
that they agreed to the study of their DNA.
No names were attached to the blood samples and
ultimately scientists used only a few of them.
These measures ensured that the
DNA sequences remained anonymous.
Not even the donors knew whether their
samples were actually used or not.
Although the human genome sequencing was
declared completed by the end of 2003, there
are a number of regions of the human genome that
are unfinished. Small gaps that are unrecoverable
in any current sequencing method remain, amounting
for about 1 percent of the gene-containing
portion of the genome. These include:
• The central regions of each chromosome, known as
centromeres, which consists of highly repetitive
DNA sequences that are difficult to sequence.
• The ends of the chromosomes, called
telomeres, which are also highly repetitive.
• There are also several loci
in each individual’s genome
that contain repetitive sequence
that are difficult to sequence.
The strategy originally established by
the publicly funded Human Genome Project
was based on a method called hierarchical
shotgun sequencing method. In this approach,
genomic DNA is cut into pieces of about 150
megabases and inserted into a bacterial artificial
chromosomes vector, and transformed into E.
coli, where they are replicated and stored.
The bacterial artificial chromosomes inserts
were isolated and mapped to determine the
order of each cloned 150 megabases fragment.
This is referred to as the Golden Tiling Path.
Each bacterial artificial chromosomes fragment
in the Golden Path is fragmented randomly into
smaller pieces, typically 1 to 2 kilobases long,
and each piece is cloned into a plasmid vector.
The resulting transformed bacterial colonies are
picked at random and sequenced on both strands.
These sequences are aligned so that identical
sequences are overlapping. These contiguous
pieces are then assembled into finished sequence
once each strand has been sequenced about 4 times.
The term contig refers to a known DNA
sequence that is contiguous and lacks gaps.
In 1998, a parallel project was conducted
by the private company Celera Genomics.
Celera used a riskier technique called
whole genome shotgun sequencing,
which had been used to sequence
bacterial genomes that smaller in size
and contain less repetitive DNA. Shotgun
sequencing randomly shears genomic DNA into
small pieces which are cloned into plasmids and
sequenced on both strands, thus eliminating the
bacterial artificial chromosomes step from the
publicly funded Human genome Project approach.
Once the sequences are obtained, they are
aligned and assembled into finished sequence.
The advantage to the hierarchical approach is
sequencers are less likely to make mistakes
when assembling the shotgun fragments
into contigs as long as full chromosomes.
The reason is that the chromosomal location for
each bacterial artificial chromosomes is known,
and there are fewer random pieces to assemble. The
disadvantage to this method is time and expense.
The whole genome shotgun method used by
Celera Genomics is faster and less expensive,
but it is more prone to errors due to
incorrect assembly of finished sequence.
It also required tremendous computational power.
Which method is better? It depends on
the size and complexity of the genome.
With the human genome, each group believes
its approach to be superior to the other.
It is worth mentioning that Celera had access to
the publicly funded Human Genome Consortium data
but the Human Genome Consortium did
not have access to the Celera data.
Indeed, without the Golden Tiling Path released
by the Human Genome Consortium, the whole genome
shotgun method will not be able to determine where
the fragment of the sequenced DNA belongs to.
Because of the advantages and
disadvantages of both approaches,
an idealized strategy evolved into
hybrids towards the end of the project,
in which the Human Genome Consortium selected
more clones arbitrarily and Celera made use
of the bacterial artificial chromosomes
maps and sequence generated by the HGP.
In that way, both organizations were able to reach
their goals in less than the expected time frame.
The total estimated size of the human genome is
3.2 gigabases. Most DNA in the human genome is
non-coding DNA, including intergenic regions,
introns, repetitive sequences and so forth.
About 28% of human DNA is transcribed into RNA and
only a mere 1.25% is actually codes for proteins.
On average, the introns are longer in human
DNA than in other organisms sequenced so far.
Over half the human genome consists of
repeated sequences. Some 45% is transposons.
3% of the human genome consists of repeats
of just a few bases such as microsatellites,
Variable Number Tandem Repeats and etc. And 5%
of the human genome is made up of duplications
of large genome segments. There are both AT-rich
regions and GC-rich regions in the human genome.
Curiously, the zones of GC-rich
sequence have a higher density of
genes and the introns are shorter. The
significance of this is still unknown.
One of the biggest surprise in the human genome
is the revelation that humans only have around
25,000 genes rather than the previously
estimated 100,000 genes. The nematode worm,
Caenorhabditis, with approximately 18,000 genes,
has half as much genetic information as humans.
The mouse, have essentially the
same number of genes as humans.
Thus, the genome size is not directly
related to its biological complexity.
Another surprise of the human genome is that
only a third of the genome code for protein.
The other two thirds are DNA that we are
yet to find out what their function is.
These findings have significant implications
on how we understand the basic science of how
life works, but also how those sequences, which
are regulatory, can affect health and disease.
However, biological complexity may
presence in the expressed protein:
First, alternative splicing of a pre-mRNA can
yield multiple functional mRNAs corresponding
to a particular gene. In human, about 60% of the
transcript are subject to alternative splicing.
Second, variations in the post-translational
modification of some proteins may produce
functional differences. For example, 80
to 90% of human proteins are acetylated.
Reversible phosphorylation of proteins is another
important regulatory mechanism. Reversible
phosphorylation results in a conformational change
in the structure in many enzymes and receptors,
causing them to become activated or deactivated.
Finally, qualitative differences in the
interactions between proteins and their
integration into pathways may contribute
significantly to the differences in biological
complexity among organisms. For example,
signals from the exterior of a cell are mediated
to the inside of that cell by protein-protein
interactions of the signaling molecules. This
process, called signal transduction, plays a
fundamental role in many biological processes and
in many diseases. Proteins might interact for a
long time to form part of a protein complex, a
protein may be carrying another protein, or a
protein may interact briefly with another protein
just to modify it. Therefore, protein-protein
interactions are of central importance for
virtually every process in a living cell.
Although the Human Genome
Project is considered completed,
there are great challenges
to understand what it means.
There is still 1% of the genome at the
heterochromatin region unsequenced,
which may or may not harbor any gene.
This challenge will only be overcome by the
development of new sequencing technique.
Also, the regulatory signals for most genes remain
uncharacterized. It is currently unclear how
epigenetic modifications such as cytosine
methylation and gene silencing on a genome-wide
scale, determine their biological consequences.
The human genome sequence also identified more
than 1.4 million single nucleotide polymorphisms.
Although any two unrelated people share
about 99.9% of their DNA sequence,
some people may have an A at a particular site
on a chromosome while others have a G instead.
Further work is currently being conducted to find
genetic variants affecting health, disease and
response to drugs and environmental factors.
The scientific challenges outlined above focus
on how the genome sequence can be mined
for biological information. Ultimately,
it is the function of the gene product that
plays the integral role in the biological system.
Therefore, tremendous effort has also been
carried out to decipher the gene function.
In summary, the availability of a complete genome
sequence will enormously facilitate the solution
of the more difficult problem of identifying
the genetic components of the more complex
and more common disorders, such as many forms
of diabetes, asthma, cancer, and mental illness,
in which multiple genetic and environmental
factors interact. Using techniques that can
measure the expression of thousands of genes
at a time, scientists are now beginning to look
globally for differences in gene expression
that are associated with, for example, the
ability to respond to different drugs
or pathological states such as cancer